hey you guys flickers of fear time and i
know this is probably a very obvious
joke to make but we need to talk about
we need to talk about kevin
still funny sorry but yeah so this is a
movie that came out back in 2011 which
is really weird because i feel like this
movie's been on my radar to watch for
like such a really long time and i
didn't even realize that it was now at
this point like 10 years old and i was
like wow i really
needed to get on the ball sooner so i
remember there was a big hubbub when the
movie came out there was also a big
hubbub which i actually kind of remember
when the novel came out because this is
actually based on a novel by lionel
shriver that came out back in 2003 i
want to say and i just remember it was
like a big bestseller and it was like
you know i kind of feel like the author
was on a lot of
talk shows and stuff like that talking
about it because um this movie kind of
tackles a subject
that uh maybe was kind of like
disturbing because i don't know about
controversial i guess but it was one of
those things where if you guys saw my
review of my book review of baby teeth
uh that's that was like a more recent
book but that kind of covers the same
ground as this in that
what do you do
as a mother as a parent when you suspect
that your child is maybe a sociopath and
what like comes out of that
so now i haven't read the novel i have
like read some plot synopsis of it and
uh you know read a couple reviews of it
and stuff now the novel was actually
written in a like letter form like in
the form of the main character eva who
is the mother of the titular kevin and
she is writing a series of letters to
her husband
about
her feelings about this kid like about
pretty much like from the kid's birth
like how she reacted to him and things
like that i think they did a kind of
interesting thing in the film i think
what ended up happening with this movie
was that you know the novel was such a
big hit like it was you know something
that a lot of people were talking about
like you know culturally at the time
particularly as its uh character of
kevin uh ends up being like a sort of
school shooter type um and like i said
you know kind of looking into the
relationship between the mom and the son
and
you know nature versus nurture type of
stuff so i think that the rights to the
book were purchased like way back in
2005 and then they were kind of like
trying to get it made like for a really
long time before because i think this
was actually like a british film and i
guess they couldn't really get the funds
they wanted to make it the way they
wanted to make it so they had to like
rewrite the script so it was
not as expensive to make uh you know and
things like that so what they did
with the book being in you know in
letter form uh or epistolary style if
you want to get all literary about it um
obviously you can't really do that in a
movie so what they did they kind of took
an interesting um this was directed by
lynn ramsey by the way
and i think she also did the lovely
bones and among other things if i'm
remembering correctly
but what she did uh was decided to go
kind of like
a fragmentary
dream like so i don't want to say dream
like like too much but
this movie it doesn't really have like a
straightforward narrative it's more kind
of like i mean i didn't have a problem
following it but you know it's one of
those ones where you know the arc of the
story kind of becomes apparent but it's
not like a straightforward first act
second act third act it's more like it's
from the point of view of the main
character of eva who's played by tilda
swinton
and she's just kind of
you know i hate to say randomly but
she's like randomly remembering
various things um you know in the life
of
her being a mother to this kid who ended
up being a school shooter so it's like
everything doesn't unfold like in a you
know in a narrative in a you know xyz
type of way um it's basically just kind
of like
in the present day she's she thinks of
something and that makes her remember
something like from back in the day so
it's just it's kind of like a
fragmentary like a more of a
memory type of uh movie so what we uh
see from this
is that
eva was i guess prior to her getting
married and having kids and everything
like that was one of these very
free-spirited she was very into travel
and she was apparently a very successful
travel writer so she would like go all
over and she would like write books
about it and was very successful
she lived in new york city so she was
very urbane very sophisticated that type
of thing
now she meets her husband franklin who's
played by john c reilly who is always
awesome
and apparently what ends up happening
you know they fall very much in love
they end up getting married and then she
gets pregnant and you can tell she's
kind of uh ambivalent about it because
you know this isn't exactly how she
pictured her life going like i said
she's kind of a city girl she's like
kind of a sophisticated intellectual
type who likes to travel and i kind of
feel she you know it kind of comes
across that her being pregnant now being
like a family woman
is kind of like maybe making her like a
little resentful or like like she's
being like held down or you know the
life isn't going the way she wanted to
and it doesn't help too that you know
before the kid is born or right around
the time the kid is born
uh franklin her husband is like well we
can't raise a kid in new york city
that's no place to raise a kid so we
have to move out to the suburbs and uh
you know and she is like super super not
happy about that because she really uh
misses new york city
now
even before the kid is born
uh who will end up being kevin
she as i said she seems to have some
resentment because this isn't the life
that she wanted necessarily so there's
even a scene of her like the scene of
her giving birth where you know and like
i said this is very fragmentary like the
way they do it
but there's a scene of her giving birth
and she's basically that like the lady
keeps telling her like stop fighting it
stop fighting it's almost like she's
trying to keep the kid inside like she
doesn't want that want the reality of
the kid to like you know come to
fruition or whatever and then there's
this great shot of her just like sitting
in the bed like after the baby's born
and she's just kind of like sitting
there just staring ahead like staring
straight ahead while franklin her
husband like holds the baby and coos at
it and stuff like that so you can tell
from the very beginning that you know
she maybe harbor some resentment against
this kid
for essentially like ruining her life i
guess
but the thing about it it's and this is
interesting i think that the book
from what i've heard like i said i
haven't read it i think that the book
is maybe slightly more nuanced and
suggests more
that eva's attitude toward the kid like
even before the kid was born like as
soon as a kid was a baby went some way
toward
i don't know if it was like entirely her
fault
but i think the book was a lot more
ambiguous in whether it was her fault
like her resentment against this baby
um and her maybe treating him in a way
that she wasn't entirely aware of you
know what i mean or her just like being
distant being unable to bond with him
and things like that maybe was
responsible in some fashion for the
monster that he became i think the movie
kind of goes into this because like i
said even the author of the book has
even said that that they were worried
about when the movie was made that maybe
the trope of eva being an unreliable
narrator as in everything you're seeing
you know in the book because it's all
from her point of view so maybe she's
not perceiving things uh you know in the
way that other people would perceive
them so like i said the book i've heard
is a lot more ambiguous the movie even
though it does delve into that
and it doesn't shy away from the fact
that you know eva is resentful of having
to move out to the suburbs and like give
up her life uh for this kid
but i think because the kid in the movie
is just so obviously
a [ __ ] it's like just so obviously like
a monster
that you feel a lot more sympathy for
eva in the movie at least i did i'm not
really sure because i have seen like
some people that were talking about the
book that said well eva was really
unlikable or she was like kind of snotty
or whatever i didn't really get that so
much from the movie like i said the
resentment does come through um but
in the movie it's almost kind of like
she's trying she's trying to bond with
this kid but she's just having a really
hard time and it doesn't help that even
from you know the even from when the kid
is born he's like super super difficult
and he almost seems even from a very
young age the kid seems very
manipulative
so basically she gives birth to this kid
like i said she's not super happy about
it but she does like try she's not like
a terrible mother or anything like that
from the beginning she does try so when
the kid is a baby like before he even
starts talking all he does is scream
like all the time but only when he's
with her like that's another thing and
this kind of reminded me too of like
like i said the later book baby teeth
which was probably like inspired to some
extent like by this novel and movie as
well
but
the kid
seems like when he's around the dad
franklin he's just all quiet and
everything like that uh but when she
holds him he screams and cries and he
just will not be
comforted at all and so this is really
like
so so it's almost like this [ __ ] up
like feedback loop of you know i didn't
really want this kid but i'm gonna try
my best to raise him but maybe the kid
senses that even when they're a baby so
it's like all they do is like when this
woman is holding them he just screams
and cries and he just won't but then
when the dad who is much more like oh
baby you know and he's more into it
um but that also kind of serves to make
eva
look like she's exaggerating or she's
making things up because from the dad's
point of view the kid seems like a sweet
normal kid because he's not around uh
when this kid is like screaming his full
head off like all day long and that just
fuels eva's resentment against this kid
because now it's like this kid is acting
like this and
nobody else sees it really but her
and so that's kind of so it's kind of
like making her think like well maybe
i'm crazy maybe i'm you know
exaggerating maybe you know what i mean
so it's just kind of like this really
terrible feedback loop of misery you
know what i mean
so as the kid grows up like even when
he's like toddler age he's kind of he
goes to a thing where he's like kind of
non-verbal
um she does actually take him to a
doctor like she's like shouldn't he be
talking by now maybe he has autism so
she does seem like she's trying to go
through like jump through the right
hoops to see what's the matter with this
kid but even the doctor is just kind of
like well he doesn't really have any
other signs of that you know he seems
physically normal maybe he's just like a
little bit
slow and upticket so i'm sure it's
nothing to worry about you know what i
mean so again her feelings uh toward
this kid are kind of like invalidated
and again when this kid is a toddler he
basically as much as she tries to
connect with him and as much as she
tries to play with him you know there's
there's a scene of her just like
throwing you know let's catch the ball
and he just like sits there and stares
at her you know what i mean and he just
won't do it and she just like tells you
know say mommy say mommy and he's like
no that's like all he'll say but like i
said around the dad he's like super
lovey so the dad doesn't really it's not
so much that he doesn't know what's
going on but it's almost kind of like he
just sees this side of kevin um so he
just thinks that mom is exaggerating it
and is pissed off because
you know this wasn't the life that she
wanted and stuff which is true
but
in some ways too the older that kevin
gets
you can see how
manipulative he is and it gets to a
point where he starts to he's smart
enough to like play
the parents off one another because he
knows that you know if he's like sweet
to his dad or whatever then is like a
[ __ ] to his mom the dad's not gonna
like believe necessarily like anything
the mom says about how he's acting
because he doesn't see it and there's
like some pretty gross ass scenes in
this movie too it's like
because one of the things other than the
kid not really talking like when he's
a toddler and a little bit older than a
toddler i think i can't really tell i
think he's supposed to be like four or
five years old but he was still wearing
diapers because he was still like
[ __ ] himself all the time and it
seemed like he was [ __ ] himself on
purpose just to be an [ __ ] which
actually does come to fruition one day
where basically
the kid like poops himself
just like to be a jerk and so she's just
kind of like well you know me and so
like she goes and like changes them and
cleans them all up and everything and as
soon as she cleans them all up he starts
walking out the room and then he
deliberately shits himself again i'm
like holy crap where does this kid get
all this [ __ ] from
and then and that just makes her so
angry like it's just built up that she
throws him against a wall and breaks his
arm
and after this like she takes him to the
hospital they fix his arm she apologizes
and everything like that but one thing
that this kid does and like i said i'm
not entirely sure how what age he was
supposed to be i think he was supposed
to be like five maybe um old was too old
to be pooping himself and wearing
diapers but
you know still but you know still old
enough that he was like a manipulative
little demon so
what he does he goes to the hospital
she's like mommy's so sorry you know she
never should have done that and all this
other stuff but the kid
doesn't tell the dad franklin that mom
broke his arm he said oh it was me i was
like trying to go to the bathroom and i
fell off the
you know the porta potty or whatever and
uh you know and i and i broke my arm so
he has that leverage over his mom
because you know what i mean he's like
you know if you do something to piss me
off then i'll just tell dad that you
broke my arm and that'll be the end of
it so he's smart enough at that age
to um you know just manipulate the
feelings of the entire family he also
does some [ __ ] too where it's like every
now and then like there's one scene in
particular where eva is reading to him
like when he's sick
and
he for some reason like starts acting
super lovey-dovey toward her like she's
reading to him from robin hood and he's
just like all like loving up on her and
everything and she's just like oh my god
it's like maybe we've made a
breakthrough or something like that and
then he and then the kid is even like
dismissive toward the dad like go away
i'm with mommy or whatever and so she
gets like super happy about it but that
seems like that was another thing that
kevin did just to like [ __ ] with her
emotions uh because he's the literal
worst
now perhaps unwisely
into this situation eva and franklin
have a second child a little girl named
celia
now celia is a lovely lovely child and
eva has no problem at all connecting
with this particular baby so she turns
out very
very happy and very normal and
everything like that but of course kevin
who at this stage is kind of like a
young teenager um he's obviously not too
happy about this and it's really kind of
the the scenes of the two of them
together are kind of sad because the
little girl is obviously that's her big
brother and she'll like she like does
everything for him and she's super nice
to him and he just like calls her a
[ __ ] and all this other stuff like and
just like makes her go get stuff for him
like a slave and all this other kind of
[ __ ]
and it's just like really sad because
she looks she idolizes him because
that's her big brother uh another thing
that happens too and like i said this is
how clueless the [ __ ] dad is because
uh the kid kevin is like so into robin
hood and he's really good at archery
so for christmas one year
uh kevin gets a really really nice
compound bow which like i said you can
see where the [ __ ] this is gonna go and
that's like just
i would not have given this kid weaponry
of any
way in any way shape or form but like i
said dad was a little uh checked out or
clueless all he sees is this wonderful
boy who has an interest in archery and
let's get him that
uh and sadly celia for christmas gets a
guinea pig now
you know pretty much from the second
that she opens that up it's like oh boy
guinea pig uh yeah you know that guinea
pig's not gonna not gonna have a very
good end and indeed he does not uh
spoiler alert he ends up in the garbage
disposal uh which is pretty [ __ ] up
and at which point too celia the little
girl uh she's left in the care of kevin
like for some brief time
and uh she somehow gets like some drain
cleaner or something like that like in
her eye it essentially blinds her like
they have to like remove her eye and uh
you know just gets a glass eye as i said
this is not really laid out in order
what you're basically seeing
they start at the beginning like the
very first scene is you you presume that
it's like eva before she got married
before they um before they had the kid
everything like that where she's at that
what's that you know that big festival
in italy where it's like the tomato
festival where everybody just goes in
the street and just smears tomato sauce
all over themselves okay she's at that
she's having like a really good time and
everything but like i said they the way
they shoot it you know it looks like a
whole bunch of crowd like just covered
with gore you know what i mean and it's
that's one thing i've
you know this movie seems to have had
like
really really positive reviews or some
people like some critics like really
really hated it because they just
thought it was too like oh the symbolism
of red it's like every scene has to have
like a red thing in it like it's
symbolic of like blood and guilt and all
this other kind of stuff and then it was
too heavy-handed i didn't really find
that like i saw that but it wasn't
it wasn't like uh you know distracting
to me or anything like that but you know
you could argue that
that the symbolism like i said the
tomatoes and everything like that at the
beginning uh you know just looking like
a big crowd of people all covered with
blood or whatever um you know was too on
the nose but like i said it didn't
really bother me all that much but what
happens after that is we actually cut to
what we're presuming is like the present
day
and eva
is now like living by herself in like
this shitty house and she's trying to
get a job
and if you don't know what this movie is
about then you're just like what the
[ __ ] like is up with this woman like
she's trying to get a job and like
everyone's looking at her weird like in
the town and like the lady at the travel
agency where she goes to get a job is
she's like i don't care who you are what
you've done as long as you can do the
job it's fine but all her co-workers are
like looking at her like that like
she'll walk down the street and like
this woman comes up to her and just like
slaps her in the face like you monster
or whatever and uh you know somebody
throws red paint all over her house and
stuff so that's so they kind of start
out with that and then as time goes on
you know at one point like near the
beginning she's going and visiting kevin
in prison
so they kind of like start in the
present and then kind of like jump back
and forth a lot um and they never really
say like whether it's back and forth but
you can tell because
in the present day like tilda swinton
looks like you know she doesn't have any
makeup her hair is all [ __ ] up she
looks like
rhode hard and put up wet whereas
in the you know in the older ones she
looked like she has like you know a
professional looking haircut she looks
like all put together and everything so
you can kind of tell
uh you know which time period it is
without too much trouble
now uh at this point it's kind of like
like i said so after that happens with
the little kid um eva is just kind of
like man what the [ __ ] at this point too
evil's like look i think this kid is you
know is a sociopath and maybe we should
do something about that but franklin
just doesn't want to hear it he doesn't
see it
um he doesn't uh really perceive things
the same way that his wife does so at
this stage they're kind of talking about
getting a divorce
at which point like i said i think kevin
at this point i'm not sure how old he's
i think he's 15 or almost 16 so he's in
high school and uh he basically decides
to do like a columbine style you know
school shooting except with a bow and
arrow instead of a gun um so that's kind
of what we've been shoot like going back
and forth to like all this uh whole
entire time and he ends up like killing
all these people and like i said that's
why you see all these scenes at the
beginning
of eva walking down the street and
people just coming up and hitting her
like everybody's staring at her in the
grocery store and stuff because some of
those were parents of you know the
victims and things like that
so
this movie
i actually really like this i could see
how like some people this is definitely
definitely a horror movie but it's kind
of like a psychological drama
with some horror elements i've seen some
reviews that said they thought that it
went like i said over the top with the
symbolism or over the top with it being
kind of like campy or lurid but i don't
know i didn't really find that um it's
fairly disturbing like i said um
i did see one critic call it
birth control the movie
which like i said i think i said
something similar when i was talking
about the book baby teeth it's the same
kind of thing like if you're pregnant or
if you're like planning on having kids
you might want to skip this one because
this is gonna make you like not ever
want children but it's just kind of like
so so i don't know like i said the book
seemed like it was more intent on
not really like not coming down on one
side or the other over how much blame
the eva
shouldered for how her son turned out
you know was he a sociopath but was her
distance from him was her failure to
bond with him from a baby was that
somehow responsible did that feed into
his later behavior was he just born bad
but like i said in the book that is left
like kind of ambiguous because
you know everything in the book is you
know in letter form so it's from eva's
point of view so you don't know how
objectively that she's uh seeing things
so maybe she's an unreliable narrator as
i mentioned
in the movie like i said she does some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] um she does break her
kid's arm at one point you know just out
of frustration because he keeps [ __ ]
himself on purpose just to like be an
[ __ ] but in the movie and i don't
know if this is a failure of the movie
because i feel like a lot of critics
really didn't like this this didn't
bother me that much but i can totally
see where they're coming from because
the way the child is portrayed and
there's three different it's a baby and
then like toddler five issues five or
six and then as a teenager
um because the kid is portrayed as
essentially damien she's just like a
monster uh with really no redeeming
qualities whatsoever he's just seen as
like this manipulative little evil
[ __ ] honestly i was a lot more
sympathetic like even when i know this
is a terrible thing to say but it's like
you should never ever like throw a kid
against the wall obviously but when that
happened in the movie i'm like yeah
[ __ ] that kid just because the kid was
like the literal worst and it's just
kind of like so so i'm not sure if that
was like the way that they wanted to
portray the kid because as it comes
across this
the movie is like seems less ambiguous
to me because it seemed like eva was
just kind of like man this kid like she
knew the kid was like a [ __ ] from the
beginning and she was just kind of like
yeah i'm not having any of this but she
did try like i said she did try to
relate to him she tried to connect with
him you know she did try to do things
she wasn't just like man [ __ ] that kid
and just like leaving him out in the
[ __ ] you know she didn't do that she
did do some things to try to like
connect with them and it just didn't
work so i think if the movie was trying
to be ambiguous in the sense that you
know was her
resentment did that have some did that
play some part in like how he turned out
like him being a mass murderer um
whereas in the movie i just kind of feel
like he was just born like that and he
was just the worst and she was reacting
to the situation in a way most people
would like if you suspect that this kid
is evil and uh you know you're trying to
bring him up because that's what you're
supposed to do but it's like you really
don't know what to do about it uh she
did like try to like fix it but it
couldn't really you know it it just
never came to fruition that it ended up
like that but um
overall like i said uh i actually really
do like this movie it's uh very
disturbing like i said it's kind of
fragmentary it's not like
um you know it's not hard to follow i
didn't find it particularly hard to
follow but you have to think that you
know it goes back and forth in time just
jumps around in time a lot um without
really
i don't know if i'd say without any
rhyme or reason but it does kind of jump
around so you do kind of have to like
pay attention to like what time
line you're in but like i said the story
is not super complicated all you're
doing is like you're following you know
the upbringing like this kid's entire
life like why did he turn out like this
so
i don't know i thought it was a good
flick like i said it's very disturbing
um it's gonna make you never ever want
children because that kid is just the
[ __ ] worst but yeah and there's some
disturbing scenes in it like i said you
know
guinea pig gets uh you know put down a
garbage disposal and so if they don't
super super show that it's not like
really graphic uh the poop stuff was
grosser to me because i'm just like
really grossed out
so i was like where this kid just keeps
pooping what does how can he do that i
don't know he just might be eating some
laxatives or something like that but
yeah so as i said this came out in 2011.
uh i think that uh tilda swinton is
great in this she's great in pretty much
everything uh she didn't get nominated
from for an oscar weirdly uh she did get
nominated for a golden globe i think in
a bafta although i don't think she won
uh john c reilly is great in this uh
he's not in it a huge amount but he's
like kind of the dad and he's just like
kind of this affable uh sort of dad dude
and he's just kind of like what he's
just
he's just a little boy he's like chill
out it's fine and everything like that
but he's just like totally clueless but
you can't hate him because the kid does
kind of like manipulate him into
thinking that he's
an okay kid when he's totally not
overall like a really good film i can
see how you know maybe they should have
gone a little bit more subtle uh with
the kids so because that would be kind
of like a more nuanced
uh sort of message rather than yeah this
kid sucks so that's just you know what i
mean
and this poor woman has had to put up
with this [ __ ] rotten bad seed like
all this [ __ ] time which is kind of
how i saw it but like i said i'm not a
big fan of kids in general so maybe
maybe your mileage may vary but uh but
yeah so check it out it's actually on i
think it's on uh hulu at the moment i
think i watched it on hulu uh but i'm
sure it's on other streaming services as
well so uh go check it out if you're
into like the
the evil kid sub genre which i actually
kind of like those
so uh yeah this is a pretty disturbing
one so uh yeah definitely check it out
and i will see you guys on the next
flickers of fear
bye